♪
Mesdames et messieurs, bonjour.
Ici Céline Galipeau.
Bienvenue à cette émission
spéciale du jour du Souvenir,
en hommage aux soldats canadiens
disparus.
Vous voyez des images en direct
de la foule réunie au Monument
Commémoratif de Guerre, à
quelques pas de la Colline
parlementaire, au centre-ville
d'Ottawa.
Le temps est nuageux et il fait
froid, - 6 degrés ce matin.
Pas facile pour les vétérans
qui se sont installés pour
saluer une fois encore leurs
camarades morts au combat,
ainsi que tous les Canadiens
qui ont donné leur vie au cours
de différentes guerres.
Il y en a eu 116 000.
Mon collègue Daniel Thibeault
est déjà sur place à Ottawa.
Daniel, malgré ce temps
frisquet, toujours beaucoup
de monde pour cette cérémonie
du Souvenir.
Autour de 30 000 personnes qui
se déplacent; leur nombre a
beaucoup augmenté au fil des
ans.
- Bon an mal an, c'est toujours
surprenant parce
qu'effectivement il fait très
froid ce matin. Malgré cela, les
parterres de chaque côté du
monument sont remplis. Il y a
des gens qui sont arrivés depuis
déjà une bonne heure et demie.
Des gens pour qui c'est
important d'être ici
aujourd'hui. C'est la grande
cérémonie au Canada. Ça se
déroule aujourd'hui devant le
monument de guerre qui a été
inaugurée il y a 80 ans par
Georges VI lors d'une visite
officielle en 1939. La
construction de ce monument
avait commencé en 1926. Les
statues de bronze ont été
acheminées en 1937 à Ottawa. En
1938 l'ensemble de l'offre a été
complété. Petit élément
d'information, ça comporte 32 t
de bronze. C'est un cénotaphe
depuis l'an 2002 - rapatrier les
restes du soldat inconnu qui
sont enterrés sous la tombe
derrière moi. C'est devenu le
monument commémoratif de guerre
du Canada. C'est ici chaque
année en plein centre-ville ou
les gens viennent se souvenir,
souligner le travail et la
mémoire de ceux qui sont tombés
au combat pour défendre tous ces
conflits dans lesquels les
soldats canadiens ont participé.
- Envoyer des images du roi
George six. C'était la première
fois qu'un monarque régnant pour
le Canada visitait le pays.
- C'était la première visite,
visite de six semaines qui
avaient permis au souverain de
sillonner le pays et qui lui
avait permis à ce moment-là
devenir inauguré le monument.
- Vous serez avec nous tout au
cours de l'émission. On vous
retrouve tout à l'heure. Merci.
Je vous présente mes deux
invités sur le plateau.
Le lieutenant-colonel Gilles
Paradis, habitué de nos
émissions, que vous connaissez
bien, retraité des Forces
canadiennes.
Et nous profitons du passage de
Jean-Baptiste Pattier à Montréal
pour l'inviter sur notre
plateau. Monsieur Pattier,
journaliste et historien
français, est l'auteur de
ce livre passionnant,
Un reporter au coeur de la
libération, sur le correspondant
de guerre de Radio-Canada,
Marcel Ouimet.
Ce jour du Souvenir souligne
l'entrée en vigueur à 11 h,
le 11 novembre 1918,
de l'armistice qui a mis fin
à la Première Guerre mondiale.
C'est un des nombreux conflits
auquel le Canada a participé.
Messieurs, d'abord, pour vous,
quelle est l'objectif de cette
cérémonie pour les Canadiens?
Ce jour souligne l'entrée en
vigueur de l'armistice à 11
heures le 11 novembre 1918. Ça
mit fin à la première guerre
mondiale. Un moment très
solennel bien sûr. C'est un des
conflits auxquels le Canada
participé. Peut-être commencer
par l'importance de cette
cérémonie, l'objectif. Vous qui
avez été déployé dans plusieurs
pays, l'Allemagne, Chypre,
l'Afghanistan, qu'est-ce que ça
représente pour vous?
- C'est un devoir de se souvenir
du sacrifice de ceux qui ont
combattu pour préserver la paix,
assurer notre sécurité
nationale, se souvenir que ces
conflits mêmes s'ils sont
terminés, il y en a d'autres qui
se poursuivent il faut continuer
ce devoir pour ceux qui sont
actuellement déployés qui
doivent porter le flambeau de la
paix. Se souvenir des familles
qui ont supporté leurs proches
déployés à l'étranger. Il faut
que la société canadienne sache
que le Canada une responsabilité
dans la paix et national passé
militaire et ses diplomates. On
doit transmettre le souvenir aux
différentes générations.
- Vous pensez des camarades
aussi.
- Des camarades qui ne sont plus
là aujourd'hui ou qui sont
revenus avec des blessures.
- Et pour vous qui êtes français
et normand, d'autant plus, c'est
important?
- C'est essentiel. Ce que vous
avez dit sur le sacrifice, en
Normandie évidemment on est
sensible à ce qu'on fait les
Canadiens durant la seconde
guerre mondiale. Ils ont
participé au retour à la
démocratie. Après ça comment
vivre le devoir de mémoire. Nous
c'est avec l'enseignement de
l'histoire à l'école, en
participant des commémorations
mais aussi au sein des familles.
Mes grands-parents véhiculent
l'occupation allemande, ma
grand-mère a vécu les deux
guerres.
- Elle a vu les soldats
canadiens.
- Oui, il y a ce lien très fort
avec ce véhicule. Les témoins
qui nous transmettent cette
histoire. Hélas le temps fait
son oeuvre et les témoins
disparaissent. Comment continuer
à perpétuer le devoir de
mémoire? Il y a des temps très
forts comme ce 75e anniversaire
de la libération d'Europe où on
se retrouve pour se souvenir.
Les grandes commémorations sont
une occasion très importante
pour rassembler les peuples et
les pays et célébrer la
libération et la démocratie.
- La cérémonie se prépare. Elle
va commencer à 11 heures
précises.
On voit Perry Bellegarde, chef
des premières nations. Vous le
disiez, il y a de moins en moins
de témoins directs de cette
histoire. Il ne reste plus
d'anciens combattants de la
première guerre mondiale. Il en
reste de moins en moins de la
seconde guerre mondiale. On peut
voir un tableau sur le nombre
d'anciens combattants. 33 200 en
tout de la seconde guerre
mondiale et la moyenne d'âge de
94 ans. Il y en a de moins en
moins. 8000 de moins que l'an
dernier. De la guerre de Corée,
l'âge moyen de 87 ans et les
autres vétérans qui ont fait la
Bosnie, l'Afghanistan, 600 000
et la moyennes d'âge est de 58
ans. D'où les cérémonies comme
aujourd'hui.
- On voit souvent les vétérans
comme quelqu'un d'âgé mais il y
a 600 000 vétérans qui ont
poursuivi la tradition de
maintien de la paix à travers
une quarantaine de missions de
paix des Nations unies qui ont
participé au conflit dans les
Balkans et en Afghanistan, dans
d'autres théâtres d'opérations.
Ces individus, les vétérans
doivent avoir notre
considération et notre respect.
- On en voit quelques uns.
Ils tiennent à être la présente.
Et une foule assez nombreuse.
On va vous présenter tout de
suite un reportage sur la mère à
la croix d'argent. C'est une
tradition ici. Une tradition qui
a 100 ans. Cette mère qui
représente un peu toutes les
mères qui ont perdu un enfant au
combat. Cette année, nous allons
voir Madame Reine Samson Dowe de
Kingston. Son fils est mort en
2007. Elle ira déposer une
couronne au nom de toutes les
mères qui ont perdu un enfant.
Un honneur qui porte avec lui
des souvenirs douloureux même si
elle a réussi à tourner la page.
- Celui à l'extrême droite,
c'est Matthew, ensuite, c'est
Pete et Philipp et James.
- Reine Samson Dawe n'a jamais
été militaire, mais elle n'en a
pas moins consacré une bonne
partie de sa vie à l'armée.
Femme d'un officier de
carrière, elle et Peter Dawe ont
eu quatre fils qui ont grandi
sur une vingtaine de bases
militaires.
Tous ont fait le choix de
porter l'uniforme.
Dans la famille, le sens du
devoir est omniprésent.
C'est ce qui a poussé Matthew
Daweà servir en Afghanistan.
Après une première mission,
rien ne pouvait l'empêcher d'y
retourner, pas même une
déchirure du tendon d'Achille.
- Ils l'ont vu en clinique, ils
ont dit : "Bien, désolé,
Matthew, tu peux pas y aller, ça
va prendre au moins un an à
récupérer." Et puis, on lui a
offert l'option de rattacher ou
faire de la réhabilition
graduelle, puis il a dit :
rattachez-le et je vous garantis
que je vais être prêt.
Et puis au bout de quatre mois,
il était prêt à partir.
- Le deuxième séjour en
Afghanistan du capitaine Matthew
Dawe, commandant de son peloton,
aura été fatal.
Le 4 juillet 2007, sur une
route à une vingtaine de
kilomètres de Kandahar, une
bombe téléguidée explose sous
son véhicule, tuant les
7 personnes à bord.
Le temps atténue la douleur...
et les parents de Matthew Dawe
sont aujourd'hui capables
d'évoquer avec bonheur leurs
plus beaux souvenirs.
- Ça, c'est toujours à Edmonton,
je pense...
- Celle-là.
- Matthew est mort le jour du
deuxième anniversaire de son
fils Lucas. C'est aussi pour lui
que ses grands-parents gardent
le moral.
- J'ai huit petits-enfants et
moi, je voulais qu'ils viennent
chez grand-maman et grand dad et
qu'ils s'amusent, puis qu'ils ne
trouvent pas une maison en
deuil.
- 12 ans après la mort de
Matthew, c'est Reine, sa mère,
qui poursuit une partie de sa
mission.
- On peut pas tous être soldat,
mais on peut tous aider en
supportant des causes.
- Sans amertume, sans colère,
elle refuse d'en vouloir au pays
où son fils est mort.
Reine Samson Dawe a plutôt
choisi de s'impliquer auprès de
l'organisme Canadian Women for
Women in Afghanistan.
- Si on fait un effort pour
éduquer surtout les femmes, il y
a un effet qui descend vers la
population très rapidement.
- Pour elle et toute sa famille,
le dévouement est quelque chose
qu se vit jusqu'au bout.
Cela fait 100 ans cette année
qu'on a instauré cette Croix
d'Argent pour rendre hommage
aux mères des soldats disparus.
Gilles Paradis, il est
important de reconnaitre les
sacrifices de la population à
travers cette mère qui incarne
toutes les femmes, les mères,
les veuves du Canada?
- Les familles qui voient partir
les proches, on ne sait pas
s'ils reviendront vivants ou
blessés. Ces familles vivent
l'angoisse. Et durant les grands
conflits mondiaux c'était
pendant des années qu'on devait
subir cette angoisse et le
courrier n'arrivait pas
régulièrement. Les familles
pouvaient attendre des semaines
et des mois avant de recevoir
une lettre. Pendant ce tout ce
temps, est-il mort ou blessé?
Les familles devaient être
honorées également.
- Vous avez eu la chance de
tomber sur des lettres que
Marcel Ouimet, correspondant de
guerre de Radio-Canada au moment
du débarquement de Normandie de
cette campagne, vous avez fait
ce livre extraordinaire parce
qu'important, Marcel Ouimet
donne une voix aux soldats
canadiens.
- C'est un grand reporter
présent partout à tous les
grands événements de libération
de l'Europe. Il était intégré au
corps armé et débarque avec le
régiment de la Chaudière. Il
parle de ce que vivent les
soldats au contact des civils.
Quand on parle de libération, ce
sont des soldats qui apportent
la libération des peuples.
La façon dont il écrit ses
rapports dans ses lettres ou ses
reportages, c'est absolument
exceptionnel. C'est un grand
témoin. Il va parler de ce que
vivent les soldats sur le
terrain.
- On attend l'arrivée de Justin
Trudeau et ensuite la mère à la
croix d'argent et la gouverneur
général. On peut écouter un
extrait du reportage de Marcel
Ouimet.
- Ici Marcel Ouimet,
de Radio-Canada,
qui vous parle de France.
Les premiers Français que j'ai
vus en France, ce sont ceux
de Bernières, des Normands pour
la plupart, quelques Parisiens
aussi qui étaient venus
à la plage pour une vacance.
Ce sont eux, leurs femmes
et leurs filles qui ont lancé
des fleurs à nos troupes comme
elles défilaient dans les rues.
Pourtant, au cours de la nuit,
ils n'avaient pas beaucoup
dormi. Et pour plusieurs,
le débarquement signifiait
la perte complète leurs biens
matériels. Mais tout de même,
ils se montraient heureux,
ils trouvaient la force
de sourire et de crier
"Vive l'Angleterre, vive
le Canada, vive l'Amérique",
certains de nos soldats
répondant "Vive la France!"
- Intéressant cette rencontre
des Français qui découvrent des
soldats qui parlent français
quand même.
- J'aime mais les Normands
auraient pu penser que des
soldats parlaient la même langue
que. Ça commence à Juno Beach.
Très vite les Normands les
rencontrent ces soldats et les
scènes de fraternisation, ils
vont pouvoir parler.
- Justin Trudeau arrive en
compagnie de son épouse. Pour
cette cérémonie qui va commencer
officiellement à 11 heures. Vous
le disiez, c'est fascinant
d'entendre les anciens
reportages, les témoignages
direc de Marcel Ouimet, de cette
période dont on se souvient.
- C'est la plus grande opération
de l'histoire de tous les temps.
- C'est un trésor d'informations
ses reportages parce que c'est
le vécu des soldats. Il
accompagne les soldats du
régiment de la Chaudière dans
leur combat de maison en maison.
Il envoie ce reportage chaque
soir pour informer les gens de
ce que sont les combats et les
rencontres avec les civils.
- Justin Trudeau est accueilli
par le ministre de la défense et
des membres de la légion
canadienne.
Le général Vance elle a déjà
présente. Et la gouverneur
général Julie Payette va arriver
dans quelques minutes.
On va poursuivre avec Marcel
Ouimet, parce que quand même
c'est intéressant parce qu'il
écrit aussi des lettres à sa
femme. Vous les avez recueillis.
Ils sont dans ce livre. Il se
permet dans ses lettres d'être
un peu plus libre sur ce qu'il
dit. Les correspondants à
l'époque étaient quand même
soumis à la censure militaire.
Ils faisaient leur travail au
sein de l'armée. Ces lettres là,
il dénonce notamment les
bombardements des alliés.
- Marcel Ouimet était insensible
au vécu des civils est bien
choqué quand il voit le
traumatisme des civils. Il
s'interroge dans ses lettres sur
le pourquoi des bombardements
des villes et des civils.
- Mme Dowe arrive. Vous a
présenté son portrait tout à
l'heure.
- On peut remercier les trois
filles de Marcel Ouimet qui ont
accepté que ces lettres soient
rendues publiques. Grace à ces
lettres et aux écrits de leur
père on peut réfléchir à
l'histoire et garder ce devoir
de mémoire, entretenir le devoir
de mémoire à travers ces
lettres.
- Sur les bombardements, ce sont
des questions que les historiens
se sont posés plus tard.
Pourquoi des bombardements comme
ça, beaucoup d'erreurs ont été
faites?
- Il parle de précision
mathématique dans ses
reportages. Or de nombreuses
bavures ont eu lieu. Il se rend
compte qu'il y a des problèmes
quelque part. Pourquoi autant de
destruction? Ça il le révèle
dans ces lettres. C'est
absolument passionnant.
- Les bombes à l'époque
n'avaient pas la précision des
bombes modernes. Il fallait des
bombardements massifs.
- J'aurais dû lui avant, pendant
et après le bombardement.
- Les Allemands s'étaient
retranchés en force dans les
villages et pour poursuivre
l'offensive il fait les retirer
ces Allemands. On les force à se
rendre par des bombardements.
- Voici le cortège de Madame
Julie Payette qui arrive et qui
devrait être accompagné de son
fils qui a 16 ans aujourd'hui.
- Et les lettres de Marcel
Ouimet, des millions de lettres
ont été envoyés par les soldats
canadiens à leur famille.
Il faut garder ces lettres.
- Très important. Madame Julie
Payette arrive et elle sera
seule finalement pour cette
cérémonie.
Elle est bien sûre la chef, la
commandante en chef les forces
canadiennes. Elle porte un
uniforme cette année de l'armée
de terre. De l'armée.
Elle va être accompagnée pour se
rendre et recevoir le salut
royal.
(musique)
(O Canada)
C'est la troisième cérémonie
du Souvenir pour Julie Payette
à titre de gouverneure générale.
Elle a assisté à plusieurs
évènements commémoratifs
au cours des derniers jours,
notamment en Normandie,
aux Pays Bas et en Pologne.
Elle a envoyé ce matin un
message aux Canadiens. Elle dit
que trop nombreux sont ceux qui
ont fait le sacrifice ultime. Il
faut toujours défendre l'égalité
et la tolérance. Il dit que nous
avons le devoir de mémoire
aujourd'hui et à jamais.
Il fait gris à Ottawa, un temps
propice à des cérémonies.
- Très représentatif des
températures dans les théâtres
d'opérations combattait les
Canadiens il y a 75 ans.
- Marcel Ouimet décrivait un peu
ce temps très froid. Il a dormi
dans des tranchées avec des
soldats et c'était des
conditions extrêmement
difficiles.
- Dès le débarquement. C'est
important de souligner ce point
là. Il dort dans une tranchée le
16 juin au soir. On parle
souvent des correspondants de
guerre comme Ernest Hemingway
mais il n'était pas là le 6 juin
au soir. Marcel Ouimet a dormi
là dans des conditions
extrêmement difficiles. Il
décrit ces divines itinérances
et où il faut rappeler que la
mort rôde partout. Il était
témoin de cela et le raconte
dans ces lettres.
- Il était le seul correspondant
francophone avoir assisté à ce
débarquement. Il parle de
l'Italie en 1943 et fini à
Berlin en 1945 avec la chute
d'Hitler.
- C'est le seul récit
francophone du jour J. Et quand
on travaille sur cette histoire,
il y a un chercheur ici au
Canada qui travaille dessus,
mais quand on regarde cela, il
est rien de pareil à Marcel
Ouimet qui était partout. Il a
même couvert l'issue de la
seconde guerre mondiale ...
je lui payais tes entretiens
avec Madame Dowe.
Beaucoup de gens ici viennent et
veulent rendre hommage à tous
ces anciens combattants. Il y a
un nouvel intérêt?
- Depuis une trentaine d'années
on a vu progressivement intérêt
de la population envers ce jour
du Souvenir, se rappeler que ces
soldats sont nos proches, nos
fils, nos pères, nos grands-
pères. Avec les reportages
effectués par les chaînes de
télévision, on a vu les soldats
en opérations. Le lien s'est
tissé entre les militaires et la
population générale. On sent
maintenant de plus en plus que
ce sont les nôtres et qu'ils
font un travail extraordinaire
pour préserver nos valeurs.
- En fait, c'est une grande
différence avec il y a 30 ans.
Ça beaucoup évolué. Il y a 30
ans les gens ne portaient pas
porter leur uniforme pour aller
dans les villes. C'est quand
même extraordinaire.
- Oui, il y a une époque, le
gouvernement interdisait aux
militaires de se présenter dans
les commerces au retour de leur
entraînement avec leur uniforme.
C'était très mal vu. Seulement
lors des cérémonies officielles,
autrement on demandait aux
militaires de se cantonner dans
leur base.
- Tout le monde va se préparer à
s'installer pour la cérémonie
qui va débuter dans quelques
instants. Moment toujours
solennel qui vient chercher les
émotions. C'est très touchant de
voir ces vétérans un peu
vulnérables mais très fiers et
dignes avec leur médaille. Il y
aura une minute de silence.
On va regarder tout ça ensemble
et se retrouver pour poursuivre
notre émission ensuite.
(O Canada)
♪ O Canada, we stand on guard
for thee ♪
(trompette)
(coup de canon)
(cornemuse)
♪ ♪ ♪
(coup de canon)
(coup de canon
♪ ♪ ♪
(cornemuse)
(trompette)
(vrombissement des avions)
♪ ♪ ♪
Ils ne vieilliront pas comme
nous qui leur avons survécu;
Ils ne connaîtront jamais
l'outrage ni le poids
des années.
Quand viendra l'heure
du crépuscule et celle
de l'aurore, nous nous
souviendrons d'eux.
Ahkomanisteskyinowayaa.
Matakomapiwatsyow.
Kiistononii Niitomapiyopii.
Otstoyimsowayii
Mataaksistyikowatyow
Kii Otstoyimsowaii
Aahktokakstimatsawaa
Aastkapisii Natosii
kyotamiskapisii Kyiskanotoniis.
Aakomonii Staaskyinowayow
Aakomonii Staaskyinowayow.
(avions)
- Interprète
- Dans le respect des croyances
individuelles et de la
conscience de chacun et chacune,
je vous invite à prendre un
moment de recueillement.
- Dans le respect des croyances
individuelles et dans la
conscience de chacun et chacune,
je vous invite à prendre ce
moment de recueillement.
- Je vous prie de vous joindre à
moi en répétant Nous nous
souviendrons d'eux.
Ils ne vieilliront pas comme
nous qui leur avons survécu;
Ils ne connaîtront jamais
l'outrage ni le poids
des années.
- Nous désirons prendre moment
pour nous souvenir de ces hommes
et de ces femmes qui ont servi
notre pays afin que nous
puissions vivre en liberté et en
paix.
- Nous nous souviendrons d'eux,.
- Nous nous souvenons également
du 75e anniversaire de la
campagne d'Italie.
Nous rendons grâce pour la
détermination de ces militaires,
pour la force et la volonté
nécessaire, pour faire face aux
épreuves d'une telle campagne.
Alors que nous nous souvenons du
nombre de ceux et celles qui ont
combattu et qui sont morts, ceux
et celles qui ont perdu un être
cher se souviennent d'un nom,
d'un visage.
Nous nous souviendrons d'eux.
Nous nous souvenons des
Canadiens et Canadiennes dont le
lieu de naissance se situe bien
au-delà des côtes du Canada,
mais qui se sont battus et qui
sont morts pour la liberté. Nous
nous souviendrons d'eux.
C'est avec une profonde
gratitude que nous nous
souvenons de nos anciens
combattants et de nos militaires
toujours en service qui souffre
de blessures physiques ou
psychologiques.
Puissions-nous également faire
preuve d'une grande compassion
envers ceux et celles qui ont
mis fin au combat de leur vie
parce que la souffrance...
la souffrance était trop vive.
Et que le désespoir les
empêchait de voir une issue.
Nous nous souviendrons d'eux.
La vie est plus forte que la
mort. Nous prions pour les
dirigeants de ce monde et pour
ceux de notre pays, notre
souveraine Élisabeth II, la
gouverneure générale, premier
ministre...
ainsi que le chef d'état-major
de la défense.
Nous sommes rassemblés dans un
esprit de réconciliation afin de
manifester les uns aux autres
notre détermination à faire
tomber les barrières de la
division.
Cherchons à établir le dialogue
les uns avec les autres dans
tous les domaines, sociales,
politiques, et religieux.
Afin de parvenir à une paix
durable.
Qu'il en soit ainsi et
puissions-nous tout nous
efforçait de poursuivre nos
efforts pour construire un monde
meilleur.
Amen.
(coups de canon)
- Le cortège royal va déposer la
couronne.
♪ ♪ ♪
(coups de canon)
- La gouverneure générale vient
de déposer une couronne au nom
de tous les Canadiens. Les
dignitaires vont le faire
ensuite ainsi que le corps
diplomatique. Vous entendez la
chorale des jeunes d'Ottawa qui
chante Au champ d'honneur, un
champ qui parle de ces fameux
coquelicots qui poussaient sur
les champs de bataille de repos
pendant la première guerre
mondiale. Le coquelicot qui est
devenu symbole du souvenir dans
le cadre des campagnes de
financement de la légion royale
canadienne qui recueille autour
de 16 millions de dollars encore
aujourd'hui avec les petits
coquelicots que l'on porte et
que les gens iront déposer dans
quelques minutes sur la tombe du
soldat inconnu pour se souvenir
de cette journée, de cette
cérémonie qui commémore
l'armistice, bien sûr, afin de
la première guerre mondiale mais
également tous les autres
conflits, les autres guerres
auxquelles le Canada a
participé. Voici le premier
ministre Justin Trudeau qui
dépose une couronne à son tour.
On va retrouver maintenant
Daniel qui a assisté à cette
cérémonie comme nous. Une
cérémonie empreinte d'émotion,
très solennelle bien sûre. Vous
avez participé, vous avez
assisté à un autre travail de
mémoire parce que vous avez été
plutôt cette semaine au
cimetière national où sont
enterrés de nombreux militaires
et vous avez rencontré de jeunes
élèves.
- Voilà. La cérémonie
d'aujourd'hui, c'est le point
culminant de la semaine du
Souvenir. Il y a des activités
d'un bout à l'autre du pays et
des expositions, des soupers,
Davézieux demande documentaires,
des cérémonies. Et au cimetière
militaire national du Canada, la
semaine dernière, le groupe
d'écoliers s'est donné rendez-
vous pour aller commémorer,
souligner la mémoire des
militaires qui sont enterrés là-
bas. Ils se sont munis de petits
coquelicots qu'ils sont allés
déposer sur chacune des tombes
en lisant à voix haute le nom de
la personne qui était inscrite
sur la pierre tombale. Signe de
respect pour se souvenir. Je me
suis entretenu avec un certain
nombre des écoliers.
- Je me sens triste et
privilégié en même temps.
Triste parce qu'on peut voir
toutes ces personnes mortes
et c'est vraiment triste de voir
toutes les personnes, mais c'est
aussi un privilège parce que
bien on regarde aux personnes
qui ont gardé notre pays
en sécurité.
- C'est un peu triste, mais
c'est aussi contente qu'ils ont
fait quelque chose.
- L'armée est là pour
si ça arrive encore,
mais je veux vraiment pas
que ça arrive encore.
- Très poignant est touchant de
voir ces jeunes qui prenaient le
temps sur chacune des pierres
tombales pour regarder
attentivement. Certains
trouvaient des liens de parenté
avec des individus là-bas, qui
se souvenait de leur grand-père,
d'une tante qui a servi et c'est
un peu à l'image de ce que vous
allez voir, à la fin de la
cérémonie, quelque chose qui a
commencé il y a quelques années.
Il y a vraiment beaucoup de
monde autour du monument
commémoratif de guerre du Canada
après le dernier défilé quand
les gens vont quitter, le public
qui est massé le long de la
place va se diriger vers la
tombe du soldat inconnu sur
laquelle ils vont déposer leur
coquelicot. C'est le dernier
hommage qui est rendu dans le
cadre de cette cérémonie.
- Un moment très fort. Merci.
Je reviens avec nos invités,
Gilles Paradis lieutenant-
colonel à la retraite et un
historien. Une façon de
s'engager à ce devoir de
mémoire.
- Oui, de plus en plus les
écoles amènent les jeunes
aujourd'hui Souvenirs pour
participer à la cérémonie et on
leur fait comprendre la
signification de cette cérémonie
et les enseignants les préparent
avant cette cérémonie pourquoi
les soldats ont dû aller à
l'extérieur du pays pour
défendre le Canada.
- Et ça se fait ailleurs, en
France notamment.
- Oui bien sûre en terre
normande ou les soldats
canadiens ont débarqué, des
jeunes lycéens ont déposé des
petites bougies sur les tombes
canadiennes. Les jeunes sont
impliqués dans ce devoir de
mémoire qui passe par des
actions notamment dans les
cimetières mais aussi au bord de
la mer. Il y a un groupe de
jeunes qui a lu tous les noms
des soldats canadiens durant
toute une nuit quelque temps
avant le 6 juin face à la mer
dans ce lieu de mémoire parce
qu'il ne faut pas oublier qu'il
y a des lieux de mémoire en
Normandie et il y en a de
nombreux et quand on est
confronté à l'esprit du lieu,
généralement les commémorations
sont très fortes.
- Ce que l'on a pas chez nous
parce que le Canada n'a pas été
impliqué directement. Les
Canadiens n'ont pas vécu de
guerre sur le territoire.
- Non, on n'a pas connu de
telles guerres des choses aussi
affreuses que l'occupation de la
destruction des biens, la perte
d'enfants et de parents lors des
bombardements. Ce devoir de
mémoire, on doit le perpétuer à
travers des liens étroits entre
le Canada et les pays avec
lesquels on a combattu.
D'ailleurs en France, il y a le
centre Juno de la plage ont
débarqué les Canadiens et si
vous allez faire un tour en
France, il faut aller faire un
tour. Il y a un lien étroit qui
s'est établi ou se renforce
entre le Canada et la France.
- Qui reçoit des millions de
visiteurs.
- Cela fait parti du deuxième
peut-être plus grand musées de
commémoration du débarquement du
travail historique et
scientifique. C'est un lieu très
important qui combine à la fois
une présence physique là où les
soldats canadiens ont débarqué
et un lieu où on réfléchit,
pédagogiques et de transition,
transmission de la mémoire.
- C'est sûr qu'aujourd'hui, on
les honore, on commémore tous
ces événements et on se souvient
d'eux, mais de quoi sera fait
demain pour les anciens
combattants? Il y a encore
beaucoup de frustration par
rapport à ce qu'ils reçoivent.
Les fonds de retraite, la façon
dont ils sont traités, on sent
beaucoup de méfiance chez les
anciens combattants face à un
gouvernement qui ne leur a pas
donné tout ce qu'ils espèrent.
- Au cours des récentes années,
il y a eu des coupures
importantes au ministère des
anciens combattants et au centre
de soutien au vétéran qui a été
aboli durant le gouvernement
Harper et qui a été rétabli avec
le gouvernement Trudeau. Mais il
y a encore cette culture
bureaucratique qui a peut-être
persisté un peu trop longtemps
au ministère des Anciens
combattants souvent démunis,
blessé avec des problèmes
psychologiques, de la difficulté
à faire reconnaître leurs
blessures ou des traumas
psychologiques et il devait
passer à travers un véritable
champ de mines pour se faire
diagnostiquer, avoir un suivi
consistant et avoir un soutien
pour leur réintégration à la vie
civile et ensuite un soutien
permanent de spécialiste en
psychologie.
- Cela manque toujours. Il y a
encore des problèmes. Et on
attend peut-être de voir qui
sera nommé au ministère des
Anciens combattants.
- Ce sera un signal important de
voir si c'est un ministre de
premier plan. Souvent c'est un
ministère de second ou troisième
ordre où on envoie une personne
qui avait été démis de ses
fonctions ou si c'est un premier
pas vers un ministère plus
important. Il faut quelqu'un qui
est stable, bien appuyé par sa
bureaucratie et qui est là pour
servir les vétérans.
- Parce que ça reste difficile.
Il y a 3000 anciens combattants
qui auraient fait appel à des
rejugés qui se retrouvent à la
rue carrément. En France, je ne
sais pas comment sont traités
les anciens combattants. Un peu
partout aux États-Unis aussi
c'est très difficile de
réintégrer la vie civile.
- Oui parce qu'il y a un
sentiment de solitude, vous
retrouvez vos proches et ils
n'ont pas vécu ce que vous avez
vécu. Un ancien soldat avait
vécu cette solitude et il y a un
accompagnement France qui existe
pour le retour contemporain des
conflits actuels, mais après la
seconde guerre mondiale ça été
difficile pour les Français. On
avait eu une cérémonie très
émouvante où il y avait les
fantassins qui ont débarqué en
secteur britannique et il a
fallu attendre 2014 pour voir
ces hommes recevoir de la Légion
d'honneur.
- Parce que la France était
occupée à cette époque.
- Bien sûr. Exactement. C'est
très compliqué d'ailleurs pour
avoir des Français dans les
effectifs du débarquement. Il y
a eu seulement 177 Français il
fallait quitter la France et
traverser la Manche ou passer
par l'Espagne. L'occupation
change complètement la donne
pour rejoindre les forces
armées.
- Il n'y avait pas de
journalistes français.
- Le média français est à Paris
et Paris est occupée. Radio
Paris, il fallait écouter en
catimini la radio de Londres
avec les Français mais en termes
de récits radiophoniques du 6
juin, en langue française, il y
avait des journalistes
francophones à la presse écrite
mais en récits radiophonique...
- D'où l'importance de notre
ancien correspondant. On aura la
bénédiction dans quelques
instants que l'on va écouter
ensemble et on se retrouve tout
de suite après.
(chant)
(cornemuse)
- Vous voyez ces images de la
cérémonie à Ottawa. On attend la
bénédiction et ensuite ce sera
le défilé des anciens
combattants de tous ceux qui
sont présents et tous les
dignitaires vont se déplacer
pour aller observer, assister à
ce défilé dans quelques
instants.
On parlait de l'importance d'un
correspondant dans ce genre de
couverture parce que c'était le
seul journaliste francophone
avoir assisté à tout ça. On va
parler aussi de toutes ces
batailles, parce qu'il a pu
faire une grande partie de cette
campagne.
- Les troupes canadiennes après
le débarquement ont dû combattre
férocement contre une défense
allemande tenace qui avait
l'ordre d'Hitler de tenir à tout
coup. Et puis les batailles de
Caen, de falaise et la
libération en France à Dieppe
très importante pour les
Canadiens, le raid de 1942 qui
avaient été sanglant pour les
Canadiens et ensuite la
poursuite vers la Belgique, la
libération, la campagne de
Hollande. Tout cela amenait des
pertes de plusieurs milliers de
soldats canadiens dans des
conditions absolument
épouvantables.
- Et on a ce témoignage de
Marcel Ouimet qui donne une voix
aux soldats et qui nous explique
comment tout ça se passait.
- C'est très précieux parce que
c'est inédit et effectivement,
le front se déplaçait notamment
de la bataille des Pays-Bas et
se déplaçait très vite et
ensuite ses incursions pour
raconter ce qui se passe, il y
avait des centaines de
kilomètres dans le froid, la
pluie et il rentrait écrire ses
reportages. Les soldats
canadiens ont vécu vraiment une
campagne très difficile dans
cette bataille qui est hélas
peut-être un peu trop oubliée
par rapport au débarquement.
- Dans cet espace sacré pour
nous souvenir.
Nous sommes ici pour nous
souvenir et pour exprimer notre
gratitude.
Nous voulons être reconnaissant
envers l'engagement de ceux qui
se sont sacrifiés, tant de
Canadiens aimés se sont
sacrifiés et acceptent de se
sacrifier sur terre, en mer,
dans l'air. Nous reconnaissons
les survivants, les endeuillées,
les combattants. Nous
reconnaissons les peuples
autochtones, les francophones,
les anglophones, ainsi que les
lieder de différentes
communautés culturelles. Nous
les remercions aujourd'hui de
défendre les libertés. Nous
remercions les jeunes anciens
combattants et les anciens
combattants plus âgés. Ils se
sont engagés pour combattre le
mal.
Ceci dans l'objectif de défendre
les droits de tout le monde.
Nous apprécions leur
participation. Nous apprécions
leur bravoure. Nous apprécions
leur dignité. Nous apprécions
leur dévouement. Nous apprécions
leur amour du Canada.
Nous apprécions qui se sont
engagés envers le maintien de la
paix.
Nous apprécions qu'ils aient
risqué leur avenir pour nous.
Nous savons que même s'ils
reviennent au Canada, complet et
sans blessures physiques, ils
ont subi des blessures
psychologiques.
Nous apprécions le dévouement de
chacun et du fait qu'il nous
rappelle ce que ça veut dire
être canadien.
Que ceux qui ont été blessés
soient guéris dans leur tête,
dans leur âme et dans leur
corps. Que le monde puisse vivre
sans terreur, dans le calme.
Comment continuer à remercier
nos anciens combattants? En les
accueillant, en les étreignant,
en leur exprimant notre
appréciation partout, tout le
temps. En apprenant à nos
enfants avec elle. Nous leur
devons notre vie. Soyons à la
hauteur de leur sacrifice au
Canada.
Alors que nous célébrons le 75e
anniversaire du débarquement,
nous pensons à ce jour, qu'est-
ce que ça veut dire. Ce n'est
pas spécifique mais je pense
qu'on peut faire de cette année
une année cruciale, une année
forte. Comment est-ce qu'on
fait? Et bien on fait en sorte
d'honorer ce que nos anciens
combattants ont voulu protéger.
Nous devons protéger notre
destinée en tant que pays.
Aujourd'hui, nous devons
utiliser diligence, discipline
pour atteindre le rêve
Canadiens, que Dieu bénisse nos
anciens combattants. Que Dieu
bénisse les troupes, que Dieu
bénisse tout le monde, que Dieu
bénisse le Canada.
Amen.
(applaudissements)
(musique)
Que Dieu protège
notre gracieuse reine,
longue vie à notre noble reine.
Que Dieu protège la reine.
Rends-la victorieuse,
heureuse et glorieuse.
Que soit long son règne sur
nous. Que Dieu protège la reine.
(en anglais)
alors voilà pour la partie plus
solennelle de la cérémonie. Les
dignitaires vont maintenant se
placer pour le défilé des
anciens combattants. C'est qui
vont reprendre leur place dans
cette cérémonie et qui vont
défiler. Ils vont montrer leur
couleur. Chaque régiment va
porter ses couleurs.
- Chaque service, avion, marine,
les vétérans, la réserve, on
pourra peut-être voir des
vétérans habillés
traditionnellement. Il y en a
dans des groupes de soutiens
aussi importants leur médaille
et leurs écussons. Si jamais les
gens les voient dans les rues,
n'hésitez pas à aller leur
parler. Ils seront très heureux.
Ils seront heureux de vous
raconter la signification de
leur carrière, de chaque insigne
qu'il porte.
- On voit Julie Payette qui sert
des mains et parle à certains et
de ses anciens combattants sur
place. On parlait de Marcel
Ouimet et de son rôle, son rôle
de correspondant. On parlait des
grandes batailles auquel ont
participé les Canadiens. Il y a
eu cette bataille de Cain qui
ont permis aux Britanniques de
percer le front allemand. Je
voulais écouter un extrait quand
il est arrivé et qu'il assiste,
après la libération.
MARCEL OUIMET, correspondant
de guerre (1943-1945) pour R.-C.
- Face au drapeau lui-même,
un jeune homme chef
d'une section de la résistance,
étreint par l'émotion,
chancelait.
Devant ses compagnons,
il ne craignait pas aujourd'hui
de pleurer, de verser des larmes
abondantes parce que c'était
les larmes de la libération.
Quand soudain retentit
"La Marseillaise".
♪ Allons enfants de la patrie ♪
♪ Le jour de gloire est arrivé ♪
♪ Contre nous de la tyrannie ♪
♪ L'étendard sanglant est levé ♪
- On est quand même en 1944
alors le son, il y avait des
problèmes techniques pour
transmettre tout ça. Mais c'est
émouvant d'entendre tout ça et
c'est un des documents que vous
avez recueillis.
- Si je pense à tous les gens
qu'ils ont vécu cette
libération. Les Canadiens ont
vécu un rôle essentiel.
Ils ont dû affronter des
jeunesses hitlériennes
fanatisées comme le dit Marcel
Ouimet dans ses reportages et
ses lettres. Leur percée a été
déterminante. Quand ils rentrent
dans la ville et découvrez les
civils, il découvre cette ville
en partie en ruine. C'est
beaucoup d'émotions. Parce que
le siège de Caen a duré un mois.
C'est seulement un mois après le
débarquement qu'ils y arrivent.
Quand les Canadiens arrivent,
ils se sentent enfin libérés.
Tout ce qui était lié à la
république française était
regardé de très près par les
nazis alors ce champ de la
liberté est interdit parfois
utiliser par la résistance pour
embêter l'occupant. Mais là la
marseillais est chanté
librement. Et Marcel Ouimet a
enregistré tout ça. C'est très
émouvant et très important,
retour de la république et de la
liberté grâce aux Canadiens.
- La ville de Caen est un
objectif pour le 6 juin. La
ville devait être capturé. Ça
été beaucoup plus difficile et
plus long. Un mois de combat
acharné aux portes de la ville.
L'civil dans la ville s'attend
d'un jour à l'autre être libéré
mais s'attardait. Les
bombardements tu es des civils
malheureusement.
- On voit des images du défilé.
C'est quelque chose quand même
qu'il soit là encore aujourd'hui
pour marcher comme ça dans les
rues d'Ottawa.
- C'est très fort et je pense à
ce qui se passe en Normandie
quand les Canadiens viennent.
Ils sont acclamés et beaucoup de
jeunes voulaient voir. C'est
très important. Il y a un lien
fort entre la Normandie, la
France et le Canada par cette
histoire très importante de ces
hommes qui apportent la
libération.
- La majorité des Français nés
en Nouvelle-France vienne de la
Normandie.
- Marcel Ouimet raconte que pour
bien des soldats canadiens,
c'est un peu un retour aux
sources. C'est très symbolique
de libérer la terre de nos
ancêtres comme il le dit dans
ses lettres.
- Et parfois on ne donne pas
assez de reconnaissance aux
anciens combattants.
Et même on dit que pendant la
guerre, ce sont les Américains
et les Britanniques prenaient
tout le crédit. Il le dit dans
ces lettres.
- C'est un britannique qui
dirige les forces terrestres et
celles américains qui dirigent
la force. On a l'impression que
les Américains et les
Britanniques on la parle plus
belle. Les effectives étaient
plus importants aussi. Mais ce
n'est pas pour cela que les
Canadiens n'ont pas eu un rôle
important, au contraire. Ils ont
eu un rôle clé. Les Américains
sont très forts en termes de
propagande. Il y a aussi cette
notion de communication très
maîtrisée par les Américains.
- Peut-être que les Canadiens
ont été trop discrets.
- Les troupes canadiennes
combattaient soient un haut
commandement britannique mais au
fur et à mesure de leur avancée
en France et en Belgique,
l'armée canadienne se
reconstituait comme une
formation de plus en plus
puissante. À la fin de la guerre
les troupes qui combattaient en
Italie sont venues renforcer
cette armée canadienne qui était
de l'ordre de 250 000 soldats.
Jamais on avait vu une telle
force canadienne et on ne la
reverra sans doute jamais plus.
Une force d'une telle importance
sur un théâtre d'affrontements.
Je joins Kassandra Nadeau
depuis le monument de Guerre de
Halifax, où des cérémonies ont
aussi été célébrées. Il faut
dire que c'est une ville aux
racines militaires bien ancrées.
Kassandra, des centaines de
personnes se sont rassemblées
devant l'Hôtel de Ville
ce matin?
-
aucladyckolzardé2+birglutrenadve
rs.comanicdrepolissentila Qui a
été érigé devant l'hôtel de
ville en hommage aux personnes
qui ont perdu la vie
...
bgén ROCH PELLETIER, commandant
5e division Forces armées can.
- Depuis mon arrivée ici, c'est
qu'on a un lien très, très près.
On a des liens tissés très forts
avec la population. Les gens
sont très fiers de toutes les
unités qui sont dans leur
communauté. Nous avons des
unités de réserve qui sont
dispersées à travers
l'Atlantique et chaque année,
on voit vraiment un support
incroyable pour les troupes de
l'Atlantique.
ROBERT-YVES MAZEROLLE, consul
honoraire de France à Halifax
- Lorsqu'on s'enrôle, on est
prêt à tout. C'est un petit peu
comme si on signe un chèque
en blanc et il faut reconnaître
ça, il faut apprécier ça.
Puis on reconnaît tous
ces gens-là aujourd'hui.
Je joins Pierre-Alexandre
Bolduc à la Croix du sacrifice,
où une cérémonie s'est déroulée
avec le premier ministre
Legault.
- Ça vient de se terminer. Il y
avait un peu plus de 600
personnes qui étaient ici. Il y
avait bien évidemment la parade
militaire traditionnelle. On
s'est entretenu avec des gens
dans la foule. Il y avait
évidemment des militaires en
service qu'ils ont parlé du
sacrifice aussi familial d'être
dans l'armée, également des
vétérans qui nous ont expliqué
qu'ils avaient passé plusieurs
mois en Afghanistan et qu'ils
avaient perdu des amis. Ce jour
du Souvenir si à l'époque
c'était une célébration des
grandes guerres, pour bien des
gens ici, ça prend une
signification tout autre.
- Je te dirais, on a perdu
beaucoup de chums. On a
perdu des chums là-dedans.
Puis ça nous permet de nous
remémorer d'où on vient,
qu'est-ce qu'on a fait.
- C'est un moment pour
comprendre, tout le monde,
en fait, pour repenser à tous
ceux qui ont sacrifié, qui ont
sacrifié beaucoup leur vie,
parfois une partie de leur vie
de famille, pour le pays du
Canada. Puis des fois, on pense
aussi aux militaires, mais aux
enfants aussi de militaires.
Moi, je suis une maman, donc mes
deux jeunes garçons aussi, ils
font des sacrifices avec nous.
- Le monument Icitte à deux pas
de l'Assemblée nationale.
François Legault qui était
présent, il a déposé une gerbe
de fleurs ici et à marcher
devant les militaires. On va
entendre François Legault qui
vient de nous donner sa
réaction.
FRANÇOIS LEGAULT,
premier ministre du Québec
- On a un devoir de mémoire.
Des gens courageux qui ont
défendu notre liberté.
Je trouvais ça touchant de voir
la petite fille d'une dizaine
d'années qui a perdu son père,
il y a quatre ans, puis sa mère
évidemment qui a perdu son mari.
- Il y a d'autres cérémonies à
la base militaire de Valcartier
pas bien loin d'ici. Pour
l'instant dégéné vienne ici se
recueillir devant la croix du
sacrifice.
- Merci pour ce témoignage.
C'est toujours le défilé des
combattants à Ottawa.
L'implication du Canada laissé
des traces. Il y a tous ces
jeunes vétérans qui ont une
quarantaine d'années
aujourd'hui.
- Les visages des vétérans
changent. Ils rajeunissent. Il y
en a 40 000 qui sont allés en
Afghanistan. Et il y a de plus
en plus de femmes. Elles ont des
besoins peut-être un peu
différents de celles qui ont
combattu auparavant. Ils doivent
avoir un suivi psychologique que
tous ces vétérans. Dans la
deuxième guerre mondiale ce qui
avait souffert du syndrome post-
traumatique, on ne s'en occupait
pas. On les renvoya chez avec
très peu de soutien. Maintenant,
dans les forces armées
canadiennes, on se rend compte
qu'il y a un devoir du
gouvernement canadien envers les
soldats, il y a un pacte sacré.
On leur a demandé de mettre leur
vie en danger alors on doit
s'occuper de quand ils sont
retours d'opérations.
- Il y a d'autres problèmes qui
s'ajoutent quand il s'agit des
femmes, la situation qu'ils
vivent dans l'armée,
harcèlement, la misogynie,
violent. C'est pas réglé toute
cette question. Il y a eu des
enquêtes mais il y a encore
beaucoup de problèmes.
- Il y a un vieux fond
machiniste qui subsiste. On a
pris des mesures pour que les
situations cessent, mais
malheureusement cours des
dernières années depuis que les
femmes ont intégré tous les
métiers de combat, certain ont
souffert beaucoup de latitude
reproche table de certains.
- Nos soldats, il y en a encore
1700 qui sont déployés un peu
partout, certain sous l'égide de
l'OTAN, des Nations unies. En
Irak, en Ukraine, au Kosovo, un
peu partout. 1700 militaires qui
sont déployés dans des
situations pas toujours faciles.
En Irak, la situation est
difficile. Y aura-t-il une
guerre civile? Une situation
délicate.
Daniel vous avait recueilli des
témoignages.
- On est sur le point d'ouvrir
les barrières, ça se termine
maintenant. On veut laisser les
gens venir apporter leurs
coquelicots. Avant le début de
la cérémonie l'arrivée des
dignitaires, j'ai eu l'occasion
d'aller me promener parmi la
foule et de rencontrer des gens
pour leur demander pourquoi ils
étaient ici.
Qu'est-ce qu'ils veulent envoyer
comme message?
- Pour les remercier de ce
qu'ils ont fait.
- On pense aux collègues qui
sont encore là. C'est une chance
de venir ici de souligner
l'importance de ce qu'ils font.
- Je viens ici tous les aînés.
C'est important. Je pense qu'on
reconnaît par qu'il y a de la
formation militaire, l'même
c'est dangereux. Il y en a
plusieurs qui part sur une
mission à long terme ils disent
adieu à leur famille ne sachant
pas la façon dont ils vont
revenir.
- Pour moi c'est la seule
journée où les anglophones et
les francophones on s'en fout de
on vient. On se réunit et on est
fié de ce qui s'est passé.
- S'intéressant quand même ce
commentaire.
- Et c'est vrai. Cette dame qui
a été guidee à la crête de Vimy
nous disait qu'elle. Quand elle
se promenait sur le site avec
quelques logos canadiens sur
elle, les gens l'arrêtaient pour
la remercier. On lui demandait
de transmettre ses remerciements
chez elle. C'était la première
fois qu'elle pouvait venir à une
cérémonie à Ottawa.
- On a parlé de ses liens avec
la France, la Normandie. Il y a
aussi des liens avec les Pays-
Bas dont vous allez nous parler.
Vous allez nous parler des
bulbes de tulipes six important
pour les hollandais.
- Petit retour en arrière. Entre
septembre 2000 19 septembre
2020. On se trouve dans cette
période. On célèbre le 75e
anniversaire de la libération
des Pays-Bas, de la pression
nazie. Rappelez-vous à l'époque
et retournons 75 ans avant en
arrière, c'était l'début de
l'hiver, l'occupation nazie dans
les Pays-Bas, on avait bloqué
les transferts de nourriture et
de médication. On estime qu'il y
a 4,5 millions de personnes
touchées par la famine dans les
Pays-Bas. 22 000 personnes en
sont mortes de façon directe ou
des suites de maladies. À
l'époque, comme il y avait rien
qui pouvait entrer et sortir,
ils se sont retrouvés dans les
entrepôts là-bas un nombre
incalculable de bulbes de
tulipes qui sont devenues
l'élément qui a permis aux gens
de survivre. On a consommé,
manger les bulbes de tulipes.
Les hollandais se sont rendus
compte que ça pouvait être une
source de nutriments. On a
publié des recettes. Ce petit
bulbe, simple d'amitié entre les
Pays-Bas et le Canada a été à
l'époque un élément nutritif
pour la population ce qui leur a
permis de passer par-dessus. Et
il y a 75 ans la famille royale
avait trouvé refuge au Canada et
avait donné 5000 bulbes de
tulipes en cadeau. On a
redistribué 100 000 bulbes de
tulipes qui ont été plantées au
cours des dernières semaines
normalement. C'est tulipes pour
commémorer le 75e anniversaire,
vous allez les voir fleurir le
printemps prochain à Ottawa mais
aussi à travers le pays.
- Très intéressant tout ça.
Merci beaucoup.
Et justement les liens sont
tellement fort. Et vous-même
avez été un peu, vous avez fait
parti de.
- Ma belle-famille était de
l'origine hollandaise ils ont
connu la guerre. De mes beaux-
parents mangeaient des bulbes de
tulipes et il y avait aussi de
la betterave à sucre. Chacun
espérait manger l'un ou l'autre
pour changer leur ordinaire. Ils
ont réussi à passer l'hiver 1944
dans des conditions précaires.
Jusqu'à ce que l'armée
canadienne les libère.
- On se rend compte à quel point
c'était dur pour les populations
civiles.
- Marcel Ouimet dépassement de
ces gens qui étaient gagnés par
la famine. C'est ça qui est très
fort. Par des populations
civiles très vite dans ces
lettres. Maintenance pense là-
dessus mais lui était
précurseur. Il avait été pris
par sa sensibilité. Les civils
font parti de l'histoire aussi
de ces batailles. Il des
histoires militaires et aussi
les histoires des populations
civiles.
- On voit des images de Justin
Trudeau qui va quitter dans
quelques instants. Il se rend à
un sommet de l'OTAN très
bientôt.
Le temps va survivre?
Emmanuel Macron a dit qu'elle
était en mort cérébrale.
- Il a exagéré un peu. Le temps
a survécu à plusieurs crises.
L'OTAN a dû s'adapter pour
plusieurs missions. Elle
réussira toujours à s'adapter et
à faire face à ses missions.
- On disait qu'il y avait des
cérémonies partout dans le
monde. Cette année c'est à New
York que Donald Trump accompagné
de son époux a rendu hommage aux
soldats américains diarrhées
d'aujourd'hui dans une cérémonie
assez sobre.
En France le président à raviver
la flamme sur la tombe du soldat
inconnu à triomphe API. Et un
monument dédié aux soldats morts
en opérations à l'étranger. Et
hier, 10 novembre, la reine a
assisté à la cérémonie du
souvenir.
Le prince Charles a déposé la
traditionnelle gerbe de fleurs
au à cénotaphe à Londres.
Et un avion à larguer des
dizaines de milliers de
coquelicots au dessus des
falaises.
Qu'est-ce que vous souhaitez que
les gens retiennent de ces
commémorations?
- Qu'on parle jour du Souvenir,
de cérémonie spéciale mais tout
au long de l'année, souvenez-
vous des vétérans, des gens qui
sont en uniforme. Garder des
liens étroits avec ceux qui sont
revenus avec quelques séquelles.
Encourager les. Demandez-leur de
parler de leur expérience.
Remerciez-les.
- C'est différent mais il y a
beaucoup d'émotion : comme.
Allez voir les anciens
combattants, écouter les. Avec
le temps hélas, ces gens vont
nous quitter un jour. Écouter
les et recueillir leurs paroles.
Et la transmission jeune
générations me porte à coeur. On
suppose de nombreuses questions.
Et même la démocratie se compose
de nombreuses questions. Allons
vers les jeunes et expliquons
lorsqu'on fait, ce qu'ils ont
fait ces soldats et pourquoi ils
se sont battus, ces valeurs
universelles, ces instants de
fraternité que nous vivons sont
des instants clés pour ce monde
de demain.
- Pour vous servir de votre
livre pour accompagner les
jeunes et leur expliquer. Vous
serez au salon du livre de
Montréal. Merci d'avoir été là.
C'est ainsi que se termine
l'émission spéciale. Le
Téléjournal midi suit dans un
instant. Nous nous laissons sur
les images les plus marquantes
de cette cérémonie.
(chant)
(cornemuse)
(chant